[Music]
on this wednesday night ukrainians
running out of time and places to bury
their dead
ukraine's president makes another plea
for the west to do more show more
leadership the new sanctions against
putin's family and who still has no
problem doing business with russia
approved a new oil project off
newfoundland and labrador gets the green
light from the federal government
handling the sixth wave where are the
rising cases of covid leading in canada
plus answer a 23-year-old canadian
question who is jeopardy's new champion
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as evidence of atrocities in ukraine
mount the west is reacting with more
sanctions including against the children
of russian president vladimir putin and
his foreign minister and two more
russian banks but ukraine's president
says it's not enough vladimir zelinski
called out what he calls the doubts and
indecisions in europe to completely bar
russian energy imports saying some
leaders are more concerned about
business losses than with war crimes
after everything that we have gone
through
in ukraine after everything that russian
troops have done we still have to
convince
russian
foreign politicians
that we need to cut any ties of global
banks of russian banks with the global
financial system we still have to
convince europe that russian oil
cannot
feed a
russian military machinery with
new sources of funding
ukraine is bracing for the next phase of
russia's war the deputy prime minister
has urged people in the eastern part of
the country to get out while they still
can because ukraine won't be able to
help as russia's invading forces move in
crystal commansing begins our coverage
tonight in a warning some of the images
in her story are disturbing
charred instruments of war lined the
streets of bucha while shell-shocked
residents head out in search of basic
supplies
for many it is the first time they've
risked being outdoors
i didn't get out of the house at all not
at all i heard something like an
explosion my neighbor went to the
crossroad and boom that was it for him
unimaginable scenes of destruction and
death are everywhere and are
overwhelming
this grieving man is urged to get up
told they have to start digging that
they're running out of time
where possible yards and gardens are
used to bury loved ones
they came and brought this grief onto us
killed our friends crippled our people
destroyed houses despite the images
shared around the world and the
independent confirmations from
journalists and red cross personnel in
bucha russia continues to insist the
bodies in the streets there are fake
video of russian aid being handed out in
besieged marijuana is the kind of
imagery that fits the kremlin's version
of events
british intelligence says russian forces
are preventing more humanitarian aid
from getting into marijuana ukrainian
officials say that port city has seen an
estimated 5 000 civilians killed
some in russian attacks
others starved to death
in the south and east of ukraine those
who can are being told to get out now
taking into account the events in bucha
and hostimel we should probably evacuate
as many people as possible in order to
save their lives we need to be prepared
for a long
haul nato secretary general says the
atrocities in bucha reveal the true
nature of vladimir putin's war while
nato ministers weigh options to support
ukraine
many of the country's neighbors continue
to do business with russia
i have no problems paying for gas in
rubles if russia asks for this says
hungary's newly elected prime minister
victor orban it's a break from the
european union's position but orban an
ally of putin who called vladimir
zelinski an opponent
says he is willing to help facilitate a
possible ceasefire
crystal gavinson global news
london
now to the latest economic sanctions if
the point of them is to stop the russian
war they clearly have not worked and
europe continues to spend about a
billion dollars a day buying russian oil
and gas pumping money into the russian
economy the american president announced
new sanctions today a direct response
joe biden says to the evidence of war
crimes that's emerged from bucha
canada's response is to summon russia's
ambassador in ottawa to make sure he's
presented with images of the brutality
jackson proskow on the sanctions and the
calls to do more
from fresh sanctions on russia's largest
banks to a possible european ban on
russian coal the west's latest moves aim
to further punish moscow for atrocities
committed in ukraine there's nothing
less happening than major war crimes
responsible nations
have to come together to hold these
perpetrators accountable for the first
time the u.s is leveling direct
sanctions on vladimir putin's adult
daughters believed to be hiding putin's
personal assets the u.s department of
justice announced direct prosecutions of
russian oligarchs capturing a 100
million dollar yacht belonging to one of
them the justice department will use
every available tool to find you
disrupt your plots and hold you
accountable none of it has disrupted
russia's war in ukraine sanctions remain
reactionary nato leaders are wary of
doing anything that might hurt their own
economies
these sanctions will not be our last
sanctions europe's top diplomat called
out the contradiction noting since the
war began europe has given ukraine 1
billion euros in aid while still
spending 35 billion euros on russian oil
and gas
putin is able to fund this war through
the energy that has been sold to us and
has unfortunately has been doing this
for many years now
the eu has vowed to wean itself off
those supplies it may be forced to act
sooner than expected the west may also
need to consider secondary measures
against countries like china and india
who continue to trade with russia
moves with serious risks if the
sanctions go this far and it pushes
putin into a more desperate situation we
have to ask
what's next is he going to retaliate on
the battlefield it is possible that that
russia will resort to the use of
tactical nuclear weapons chemical
weapons other sorts of very powerful
weapons the emerging horrors may leave
no other choice but to take further
steps for ukraine the price of inaction
is already too high
jackson prosko global news washington
today pope francis lamented the killing
of civilians in ukraine and kissed a
ukrainian flag brought from bucha
[Applause]
he unfurled the flag at his wednesday
general audience at the vatican as he
held the faded and stained flag he said
the killing of innocent civilians must
cease
he invited a group of children who
escaped the war to stand with him urging
the crowd not to forget them and then he
gave each child a giant chocolate easter
egg
the united nations children's agency
reports 2.9 million ukrainian children
are in need of help they make up half
the refugees fleeing the war according
to the u.n refugee agency more than 4.2
million people have now fled ukraine and
7.1 million people are displaced inside
the country
ontario is increasing its support for
ukrainians who come to that province
today ontario premier doug ford
announced they'll receive access to
provincial health coverage emergency
housing and trauma counseling the
province is also setting up a new
hotline and email address to connect
newcomers to local employers ford says
ontario is expecting about 40 000
ukrainians to arrive in the province
some late breaking news from ottawa the
federal government has approved the bay
donor oil project off the coast of
newfoundland and labrador
led by norwegian company ecuanor the
project consists of several oil
discoveries about 500 kilometers
northeast of st john's the company says
when completed the deep water operation
will be capable of producing up to 200
000 barrels a day and be worth about 3.5
billion to the newfoundland and labrador
government our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson joins me now mercedes
this project passed all the
environmental approvals but the
government delayed making a decision on
it how tricky a decision was it
well it's symbolic donna of how the
government is trying to balance
priorities here this is a government
that has been very aggressive on talking
about climate change and talking about
limiting oil and gas developing it in
fact about capping it all together and
here they are announcing a project it's
reflective of the difficult times
they're finding themselves in where they
need big spending budgets they believe
which are largely underpinned still by
oil and gas spending the revenues from
those projects
underlie all kinds of federal government
spending also with what's happening
between russia attacking ukraine and the
russian oil sources being
something that western leaders don't
want to touch they'll be increasing
pressure on canada to allow access to
our reserves so it's really about the
federal government trying to balance
their priorities here and we'll see
whether they're able to do that
successfully politically with the
reaction to this project now let's talk
about the federal budget mercedes gets
delivered tomorrow the finance minister
took part in a bit of political theater
today getting a new pair of shoes
i think they fit perfectly they look
great
the shoes designed in montreal sometimes
give clues about the tone of the budget
maybe about future policies mercedes
what are you hearing what are you
expecting
high heels high spending we're expecting
this to be another significant budget as
the last ones were those were driven by
covid in this case it'll be more about
promises the government has already made
here's a little clip of what the prime
minister had to say about it earlier
today
in tomorrow's budget you will see
significant investments in housing in
supports for families uh in a way that
continues to grow our economy for
families from coast to coast to coast
for years to come
donna some of those biggest items will
be things like dental care promises of
pharmacare but don't expect that to
actually be allocated in tomorrow's
budget affordability in the cost of
living something on a lot of canadians
minds is expected to be in the budget in
terms of the government talking about it
a lot trying to calm people's fears
about inflation but realistically
there's not a lot the federal government
can do about the supply side shocks that
have caused that and finally we're
expecting there to be significant
defense spending in the billions of
dollars to react to the evolving
geopolitical situation and the reality
that canada needs to think more about
defense donna okay we'll find out
tomorrow mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thank you
we will have live coverage of the
federal budget tomorrow starting at four
o'clock eastern on global tv and online
at globalnews.ca
the latest wave of covid19 cases coming
up the political response to the rising
number of infections in canada
ontario is opening up eligibility for a
fourth covid19 vaccine dose to those 60
and older as cases and hospitalizations
are slowly beginning to rise as eric
sorenson reports provinces are taking a
different approach and how to handle it
another coveted wave the sixth if you're
keeping count is washing over the
country ontario is the latest province
to make a second booster shot a fourth
vaccine available as early as tomorrow
to anyone over the age of 60 along with
vulnerable groups that's going to be
really important for people to get that
extra level of protection the move comes
as hospitalizations have risen in
ontario from 611 two weeks ago to a
thousand seventy four an increase of
over seventy percent and measurements of
wastewater in ontario suggests covet
levels are higher now than at any time
in the past the wastewater virus is
going up very vigorously indeed it's a
kind of an early warning system and all
across ontario especially eastern
ontario those rates are increasing very
very rapidly indeed but that is not
causing the province to consider new
restrictions amid increasing social
contacts the province believes hospital
capacity and icus can manage the surge
in cases knowing that we have the
capability in our hospitals to to manage
this
this is something that we are sure that
we're going to be able to get through
there's no cause for panic that this was
anticipated but as fourth doses become
available across the country it's not
clear most canadians will get it less
than half the population has even
received a third dose and as society
opens up at the same time a highly
transmissible variant is spreading third
shots are seen as the most urgent
measure we've got to stop thinking of of
the third dose as being a booster this
is really a disease that's turned out to
be a a three-dose disease a three-dose
vaccine disease province by province
there is growing divergence on public
health measures quebec is worried enough
that it's extended its mass mandate for
public places until at least the end of
april we have to wait and see how the
progression of this wave
will
will be while provincial governments are
approaching public health measures on
different timetables they remain in
lockstep on their best advice to keep
the pandemic in check don't discard
those masks and do get caught up on your
booster shots eric sorensen global news
toronto
there are some positive signs on the
overall picture of covid19 new data from
the world health organization shows
kovid 19 deaths are falling worldwide
the confirmed number of deaths fell
sharply last week by 43 percent to 26
000. the overall number of reported new
cases also dropped by 16 percent last
week to 9 million but the who says
covid19 infections are going undetected
now as many countries reduce or
eliminate testing and change how they
track cases
stretched thin ahead can canada keep up
with tackling two major refugee crises
[Music]
you're watching global national
there's another conflict going on that's
not getting as much attention as ukraine
it's in ethiopia's tigray region and two
leading human rights groups say war
crimes are being committed there in a
joint report amnesty international and
human rights watch say hundreds of
thousands of tigrans have been forced to
flee their homes because of threats
intimidation and a campaign of violence
and it claims there are widespread
atrocities reported in western tigray
that amount to ethnic cleansing the two
organizations accused security forces
from the neighboring amhara region they
are aligned with ethiopia's government
which has been at war with tigray and
rebels since november 2020
canada has pledged to help refugees
fleeing ukraine but that's on top of the
commitment to settle refugees from
afghanistan and that process is still
far from over ottawa has committed to
bring in 40 000 afghan refugees since
the taliban takeover in august it's only
managed to resettle ten thousand as
david aiken reports there are concerns
government officials may not have the
capacity to respond to both refugee
crises
when the taliban took over kabul a
vancouver-based group canadian women for
afghan women quickly tried to get its 25
afghan employees and families out of the
country they'd been there promoting the
rights of women and girls but with last
summer's election just underway it
became difficult to reach canadian
immigration officials within days it was
clear that it wasn't business as usual
people were unavailable everything just
kind of froze for a couple of months
actually and that had real implications
for people's lives in fact documents
obtained by global news through several
access to information requests show a
government scrambling in the midst of an
election and overwhelmed by the flood of
requests for help ninety thousand emails
had piled up by mid-august and just one
in five phone calls placed by desperate
afghans to canadian officials was being
answered
five of the 25 families employed by
canadian women for afghan women did get
out but 20 families are still there and
it's why lauren oates was in tajikistan
on the afghan border trying to help i've
seen no progress at all on any of my
colleagues files
and it's getting
exceedingly dangerous for them i mean
our office has been visited by the
taliban
we've had many scary incidents and the
clock is ticking some are now worried
canada does not have the capacity to
handle a refugee crisis like the one in
ukraine and the still urgent crisis in
afghanistan
canada's immigration minister says it
does it's an enormous challenge we're
asking the system to do more than it's
ever been required to do at a time when
it's already facing pressures uh but can
we do it i don't think we have a choice
but to do it one of the themes in
thursday's budget sources tell us is
what they're calling canada in the world
and that's taken to mean more defense
spending but advocates tell us they hope
canada in the world also means more
spending on refugees and foreign aid
donna
david aiken in ottawa thank you next the
canadian hotshot bringing hometown pride
to tv's biggest quiz show
[Music]
i mean
this probably needs a don't try this at
home warning that's canadian football
league player shai ross showing off what
he can do while carrying some serious
weight it's not the first time he's
blown the internet's mind last year ross
went viral with another backflip while
casually dunking an oreo cookie in a
glass of milk another canadian has
earned some serious bragging rights nova
scotia's matteo roach debuted as a
contestant on jeopardy on tuesday night
and spoiler alert the 23 year old easily
joined the ranks of the popular quiz
shows champions as mike charley reports
this is how she did it and who is
cheering the loudest
a tudor from toronto ontario canada
matea roach
for a show about trivia jeopardy sure
missed the boat yes mateo roach lives in
toronto and the show has a policy in
jeopardy's eyes where you live is where
you're from
but go away witcha she's an east coaster
which she managed to squeeze in
nova scotia duck tolling is one breed of
this sporting dog for whom fetch should
be instinctual
matea what is retriever that's correct
and you are from nova scotia exactly as
soon as i saw the words nova scotia i
was like i need to ring in and
back home there's nothing but cape
breton pride from the grocery store to
the provincial legislature
it's very very difficult to get to the
point where mateo has gotten to be one
of the three people on an episode of
jeopardy
jeopardy just got some free advertising
now roach's run has just begun on the
iconic show although it was taped in
january who is putin yes that was before
russia invaded ukraine the aspiring
lawyer showed a wide range of knowledge
what is speed skating what is game of
thrones what is archbishop of canterbury
before closing out the game of her life
with life
what did you write down you came up with
what is life that is correct perhaps the
hardest part came after the show two
months of keeping it to herself
so uh it was pretty tough i won't lie um
because i was excited and of course
wanted to share with people her mom
patty says nobody seemed to mind like we
don't know anybody who's ever been on
jeopardy before so it's a it's a little
bit like an exclusive club i think how
it turns out is anybody's guest well
matea knows but when it comes to trivia
she doesn't need to guess mike drolie
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday we leave you tonight with a
tribute to yarny trigvison he's one of
canada's original astronauts born in
iceland he grew up in vancouver
originally a meteorologist srigvenson
was selected to become one of canada's
six original astronauts back in 1983. he
launched into space in 1997 as a payload
specialist on the space shuttle
discovery triphenson died on monday at
the age of 76. the canadian space agency
says he applied the highest standard to
everything he undertook and those close
to him say bjornie trigvason was a
pioneer a beloved friend and the twinkle
in bjarni's eye always let you know that
he saw the world in a different way
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves
[Music]
you